[Music]
next the sperm must pass through the
cervix an opening into the uterus
usually it remains tightly closed but
here the cervix is open for a few days
while the woman ovulates
the sperm swim through the cervical
mucus
which is thinned to a more watery
consistency for easier passage
once inside the cervix the sperm
continues swimming toward the uterus
though millions will die trying to make
it through the mucus
some sperm remain behind caught in the
folds of the cervix but they may later
continue the journey as a backup to the
first group
[Music]
inside the uterus muscular uterine
contractions assist the sperm on their
journey toward the egg
however resident cells from the woman's
immune system mistaking the sperm for
foreign invaders destroy thousands more
next half the sperm head for the empty
fallopian tube while the other half swim
toward the tube containing the
unfertilized egg
now only a few thousand remain
inside the fallopian tube a tiny cilia
push the egg toward the uterus
to continue the sperm must surge against
this motion to reach the egg
some sperm get trapped in the cilia and
die
during this part of the journey
chemicals in the reproductive tract
cause the membranes covering the heads
of the sperm to change
as a result the sperm become hyperactive
swimming harder and faster toward their
destination
at long last the sperm reached the egg
only a few dozen of the original 300
million sperm remain
[Music]